- Well, I know we're going to talk more
about your health later,
but I have to ask,
like, how are you feeling?
- I'm feeling great.
- Yeah?
- Yeah. I'm mean, I'm feeling so good.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Awesome. Your hair looks good.
- Thank you.
- A lot of women love this
photo that you posted recently.
So will you tell us
about it? It's beautiful.
- Thank you. It was, you
know, one of those moments.
I think my husband had
already gone to bed,
my dog was, like, snoring
in her bed next to me.
I had just finished watching "The Matrix",
which is, like, one of my
all time favorite movies.
- Oh my God, I love it.
- And then "John Wick" came on,
which is also one of my favorite movies.
- Love it.
- Love. So I was watching
it and I was like,
"God", you know, like,
"Look at Keanu Reeves
playing this character
and he's just him", right?
There's not surgery, there's not Botox,
like he's a man and he's older,
but he's still playing
this, you know, action--
- I feel like that's
celebrated more with men.
- And that was my point.
- Oh. Sorry.
- I'm not against women
getting plastic surgery.
Like, whatever works for you, go do it.
I'm not saying not to.
I just was saying, wouldn't it be nice
if there could be a "John
Wick" type thing for women?
Wouldn't it be nice if we
celebrate women at all stages?
(audience applauds)
- Men are always, like,
"Ooh, a fine glass of wine."
You know, as they age.
And like, we get gray and
it's like, "They're done!"
- And the guys always have,
like, the young, like,
the co-stars, like, a 20 year old female.
- Who would totally be
interested in them in real life.
(audience laughs)
- Right? You know, so it's
like, "Wait. What is happening?"
And why can't we have also movies
that represent women that don't look like
they're completely done.
That do look a little bit more
real. That do have wrinkles.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I think it's
all about being inclusive.
- You know, like, I've got this
thing going on with my neck.
Like, that's okay. Let's celebrate it.
- I've had these lines
since, like, junior high.
I don't care. Like, whatever. Get over it.
- I just say, "I'm super busy
on my iPad" or something,
that's what's creating it.
- Well, mine, I'm so expressive, too.
I'm like, very expressive,
even when I was young.
And I love that. It's a well lived life.
But anyway, I think all
should be celebrated.
Whatever you be.
- Agreed.